maître olivier d'argan bonjour vous êtes
spécialiste des sanctions économiques
en décidant de couper un certain nombre
de banques celles dont la taille du
bilan dépasse donc ses 1000 milliards
d'actifs dit il il exclut de fait une
grande partie du système économique
russe du système financier mondial ça va
au delà de swift comme il le dit lui
même oui parce que swift est un canal de
communication il ne faut pas l'oublier
donc c'est un moyen pour des banques
d'échanger de manière sécurisée d'entre
elles là on parle d'actifs de banques
près on peut nuancer peut-être l'impact
de ces sanctions même si elles sont très
fortes et elles sont inédites contre un
pays comme la russie qui est un
partenaire commercial majeur parce que
la russie depuis 2014 se prépare à
d'éventuelles nouvelles sanctions avec
une grande partie des actifs de ces
banques à l'étranger ont pour partie
était rapatrié du moins sur le
territoire russe donc là concrètement ce
que joe biden annonce ce soir c'est que
les actifs de ces banques aux états unis
seront gelés et il est fort probable
d'ailleurs que l'union européenne suive
la même voie et que donc de fait les
actifs qui sont présents à paris si
c'est la décision qui sera prise cette
nuit soit gelé tout comme des actifs à
londres vu que la liste des banques joe
biden a annoncé la même que celle que
boris johnson a annoncé un petit peu
plus tôt cette ce soir ça concrètement
ça va faire mal à la russie plus que les
sanctions décidées depuis 2014 et
l'annexion de la crimée on passe dans un
niveau très différentes sanctions en
2014 on avait la volonté de cibler
certaines activités mais de ne pas
couper le lien avec la russie donc ont
privé en coupé schématiquement l'accès à
une certain savoir faire une certaine
technologie à la russie notamment en
matière de production et d'exploration
gazière et pétrolière est par ailleurs
on interdisait aux banques russes de se
financer sur les marchés de capitaux
européens américains là en l'occurrence
on leur coupe complètement l'accès aux
relations avec ses banques donc ça veut
dire très concrètement que dès demain
matin des banques françaises qui de
toutes manières applique les sanctions
américaines ou des banques européennes
de toute manière arrêteront de
d'échangés commercialement avec ses
banques donc oui c'est un impact c'est
majeur et ça va avoir des incidences au
delà du secteur bancaire vrai que ces
banques russes ont par ailleurs des
partenaires
à l'export de la russie sur notamment le
secteur énergétique l'objectif c'est de
tarir les fonds dont disposent
aujourd'hui la russie pour mener une
offensive comme ça qu'elle conduit
actuellement en ukraine c'est avoir des
répercussions rapides ça va réellement
entamer les possibilités offensives de
la russie ça c'est une question complexe
parce que le problème des sanctions
c'est qu'elles prennent déjà un peu de
temps à avoir de l'effet on ne sait pas
dans quelle mesure la russie s'est
préparée et dans quelle mesure l on a
des éléments macroéconomiques notamment
sur sa dette et sur ses réserves qui
sont importantes donc on ne sait pas
combien de temps la russie pour
encaisser et de toute manière ce choc
financier puis au delà ça quand bien
même ce choc financier avait un impact
sur la stratégie militaire de vladimir
poutine il est trés inconcevable de la
part de l'avenir poutine ou de son
administration d'avouer ou d'admettre
que ce sont ces sanctions qu'ils auront
fait infléchir risque il s'est exprimé
aujourd'hui devant les milieux
d'affaires d'ailleurs vladimir poutine
qui semble effectivement afficher une
cohésion du moins de façade 1 derrière
lui oui parce que de toute manière les
milieux économiques russes ont tout
intérêt à être derrière venir poutine
parce que ces banques qui vont se voir
privé de ses accès aux marchés européens
et américains elles vont potentiellement
rencontré des difficultés et qui sera là
pour les sauver potentiellement est à
rust où cette cohésion de façade du mans
joe biden n'a pas répondu à la question
concernant d'éventuelles sanctions
visant directement vladimir poutine lui
même est ce possible aujourd'hui de
sanctionner vladimir poutine oui mais
pour quoi faire à part pour le symbole
sanctionné d d d d d âmes et l'actif de
poutine à saisir à travers le monde des
biens mal acquis par exemple oui mais
les actifs de poutine ne sont pour la
plupart de toute manière détenus par des
sociétés écrans donc ça suppose en fait
d'être en mesure d'identifier
précisément où sont ses actifs et
quelles sont les sociétés écrans qui
détiennent les actifs de la lumière
poutine est par ailleurs les actifs de
les lire poutine sont très diversifiés
donc oui ça pourrait symboliquement
permettre la saisie de quelques actifs
de vladimir poutine à des transitions
n'arrive à les identifier mais au-delà
de ça la sanction contre vladimir
poutine et c'est peut-être une surprise
de la part de joe biden aurait une forte
portée symbolique parce que peu d'hommes
d'état et a fortiori de président des
mots très démocratiquement élus sont
sanctionnés pourquoi ne l'at il pas fait
d'après vous pour rêver à garder un tout
petit peu de réserve
s'est tu